i googled myself just for this the kid
marrow wife
the kid meryl kids they were very
wholesome in the beginning now it's just
like how much are you once i can rob you
[Music]
hey what up it's your boy jesus nice and
i'm the camera
and today we'll be doing the wired auto
complete
interview you're how dieses and mero
how did you use the merrell weeks it's
like how did spider-man become
spider-man
like if you don't know that the origin
story new york city high school murals
there i'm there boom bam them i see them
across the hallway i was like hey
at about uh 15 years you want to get
together and have a show at showtime
meryl says yeah let's do that and boom
there we go
literally that easy how did jesus marrow
decide what topics to cover
we have what is called a topic meeting
uh and we discuss
the zeitgeist and what interests us the
most that we pick and choose
from that uh master list of cool
that we want to talk about
and what appeals to us the most and also
what's
very important to the people you know
what i mean because we are late night
for the people
also people just tagged us and stuff on
the internet so you know sometimes we
gotta talk about stuff
how is the thesis mobile podcast
different from the show there's no
sensors so we could say whatever we want
and if we we don't have to say allegedly
because ain't nobody gonna work
it's not worth it to try to sue us
you're not gonna get any money we're not
popping like that
also the podcast it doesn't have to be
as edited so we can do
really hot takes the night before and
also
the podcast we recorded at night so it's
kind of sexy we record it with no shirts
and it really comes through in the audio
setting what do jesus america drink on
the show
i used to slam down the bench you know
the best i decided that's before
quarantine
now i'm on sexy jesus mode sexy bod you
know what i'm saying i'm out here on the
peloton
i'm trying to get trying to get ripped
so my new thing what i drink now
quickly pressed juices all right you see
your boy is a press juice
i'm not drinking anything that costs
less than nine dollars retail okay shout
out to juice press you feel me
okay this is about that life i on the
other hand
i'm a stress father of four so i'm
sticking to my rum
and on when i'm not rummed up it is
coffee
bustelo you know what i'm saying on deck
you know what i'm saying because you
need that that's strong that raw
you know what i mean this is like
colombian coke you know in coffee format
you know what i mean
need this keep you going all day with no
food sure what channel is jesus marrow
on
if you ever ran the new york city subway
you wouldn't know we are on
showtime showtime you know what's
showing late night ah
sundays and thursday check it out it's
your chance to experience showtime
without getting kicked in the face
you know what i'm saying all right or
you might virtually all right what
is jesus and mirror that's like what is
the meaning of life dog
that question that's the question that
has no answer dog we are the alpha and
the omega we are everything dog we are
the beginning of the end
we are the snake that is eating his tail
dawg we are infinity
these are mirrors what happens when you
divide by zero
it is what happens when you have
irrational numbers divided by fractions
you know what i'm saying it is a
mathematical equation that can't be
defined
it would blow your mind no you want to
know what decent marrow is
diesel marrow is when people are like yo
use your third eye you'll be like i
can't i'm on my fifth eye think about it
wow wow there you go i'm saying
stephen hawking was studying us before
he passed away recent piece of the gods
what day is jesus marrow on sundays and
thursdays
you know the vibe i'm saying where is
jesus mural film well currently i am in
the bx
right now in my apartment you see your
sneakers haven't left my apartment in
like five months i would love to see
another person
but it is what it is so my part of the
show is to film right here in the bx
you're hey i'm out here berger county
shout out to phil lawyer you know i'm
stationed at the
p town check the patterson that's say
county
bergen county we out here you know what
i'm saying just
watching my kids run around this yard
you know what i mean but when we're
filming it's a basement
like big tigger where can i watch diesel
merrell you can watch
disney maro legally on showtime which is
paid cable which is not the regular
cable you get you got to add a little
more you got to add a little spice
you have the parsley on paid cable you
can also watch it
illegally on youtube and on fire sticks
i don't recommend that but listen i get
it
i get it so do what you got to do you
know what i mean i understand the
struggle you know i'm saying
where do dieses and meryl get their hats
well we have a
lovely amazing like top flight
wardrobe uh stylist saatrasan shout out
to her dr sasha
she blesses us with the finest
of headwear you know what i'm saying
because we both struggle with
uh alopecia of the dog ten percent our
ads come from sacha ninety percent of
our house we get
when you walk down the street and they
ask you to sign up for credit cards or
they're like hey
do you want a water bottle are you just
signing away your right life right
so most of our hats come from like chase
manhattan td bank
and uh a.m new york so shout out to them
free hats that's the way you go
okay where do jesus and meryl get their
clothes from all over the world i do i'm
not joking just the other day i got a
package
from the uk so chatra shout out to her
sacha could be
sacha back in the day if it was the
early 2000's sacha will be getting our
stuff from yellow rap bastard
but it's real that that clothing store
is closed so tata gets her stuff from
all over the place and please watch
because none of our shirts are cheap
so sometimes we have our clothes on the
show and you're like what the hell is
that what
i'm like this t-shirt is 750
how you feel there's only five of these
and i'm only wearing it once for a half
an hour to record in my sneaker closet
this is worse than one percent i'm like
jeff bezos with honey on her
wow the guillotines are ready where'd
jesus remember go to
shout out to college of mountain vista
and riverdale aka the bronze
with the sister campus manhattan cop
manhattan college i'll talk to all my
english majors i have jane eyre gang
yo i went to bcc shout out to bronx
the bronx community college broncos and
then moved on to hunter college
you know what i'm saying which was the
hunter college hawks you know what i'm
saying i'm a cuny boy
you know what i'm saying proud commuter
you know what i'm saying and my college
had his own trace style you know what
i'm saying so i was
inordinately like proud about that but
you know what i'm saying shout out to
college
you know what i'm saying you made me the
man i am today are jesus and mero
are jesus brothers if you don't know any
uh
people of color you probably think we
are we are not related we have different
parents we do not grow up in the same
house
but i get it i get it you're probably
looking at us and you're like wow dj
envy and bomani jones but no we are
totally different people
okay now no relationship whatsoever are
you
nero the number one show in late night
do you remember the number one show late
night before we were even on late night
so how do you feel about it
okay there's a bunch of people that
agree with us you feel me just like
there's bad people out there that think
that rum raisin ice cream is delicious
you know what i'm saying so there's
something for everybody we are such a
number one show late night society felt
threatened
that's why the government did not allow
us to be nominated for emmy i said it
i said it opinion is true yeah what
jesus blank what is jesus's
real name oh that seems like a question
a cop would ask
and that seems like none of your
business so why don't you binders
are you trying to bring me up on a
federal indictment why do you want to
know my real name what's wrong with
jesus nice that's a better name than
what my parents picked mind your
business
what beer does jesus drink if you don't
know this then what do you like
you already know the vibes mr becks are
decatur if that doesn't work i'll do a
honeycomb if that doesn't work i would
drink an ipa
just to be an obnoxious jerk in a bar
and be like hey have you ever had
bluefish
i brewed this myself so yeah the answer
is bex you know what mr beck's on
decatur
you know what i'm saying all right
questions for mirror why
merrell why does the kid mirror wear a
hat we already know this question this
question is anti-dominican but we're
gonna ask you anyway
mirror why do you wear a hat i wear a
hat because me and my hairline parted
ways
in my mid-twenties you know what i mean
a lot of y'all do this and this is
called hairline shame you know what i'm
saying it is
different than any other type of shaming
king shaming you know what i mean
it's the same thing you're shaming the
guy that likes to do bdsm and cbt and
stuff like that listen
let me live all right mirror was allowed
to wear a hat that's right
this is america and this one is for
jesus
where jesus where does jesus nicely
where do i live i mean it's no big deal
it's just the greatest burrow
in the world and the greatest city in
the world bx all day new york city born
here
my parents came in from jamaica they
landed in the bronx i'm still here
you see it in the bodega when you see me
in the chinese food store you're like
doesn't that guy have a showtime show
and i'm like yeah but i'm still in the
bronx you run up you get your face cut
you know the vibes i ain't get nominated
for emmy so i'm keeping it grimey
[Music]
where did jesus grow up um
i will uh refer to my last answer bs all
day you know
233 you know the vibe shout out to the
homies two two three two i d
i e b x all day not leaving new york you
know i say i'm running for mayor one day
and my whole
stance is going to be we selling rolling
papers for cheap and open containers for
everybody even homeless people let's go
what is the kid mero's age because
apparently we are doing demographics or
something
i'm 37 years old i have uh four children
and i'm watched you know what i mean
people ask me this all the time
uh i don't know why do i look younger
you know what i'm saying
i appreciate y'all that think that i'm
like 25 and like that you know what
i mean
shout out to y'all but i'm actually 37
years old you know what i mean which in
bronx years is 838.
true true and next question what is
miro's favorite bodega item when you
want a bodega what's
do you a must cop and i know it's not
condoms
definitely not condoms numero's favorite
bodega item
is a nice ice cold
snapple you know i'm saying the classic
lemon tea
you know what i'm saying like you can't
beat it i mean it takes me back
to my younger years you know what i mean
when it was like snapple was like a
fancy drink
remember that was that what was like
high-end iced tea but that's it and pre
uh tv merrell i would say a new port
100. you know what i'm saying but
that's on the low is jesus
is jesus a nickname jesus is a nickname
some people say yes my parents would
definitely say yes
but um seeing as i am a manchurian
candidate and i was raised by the cia to
eventually overthrow antigua
um yeah i'm gonna say it's not a
nickname it's actually the file name
for the process i was sent through my
actual full name is jesus
hyphen 2478.jpg
do not run me through mcafee i
definitely got a virus
that's right you know what i'm saying
this is actually acronym i can't even
tell you what it is
because then i'll be murdered here's the
question from aero where is the kid
mirror from all right come on you know
what it is bx all day easter everybody
do we have you know what i'm saying
forty side we out here we did it
you know what i'm saying but i moved all
around the bronx so shout out to all the
neighbors
i'm saying shout out to king's bridge
i'm saying shout out to 176.
shout out to mount eaton uh hoffman
hughes uh
university uh if i keep going i'm just
going to keep going forever so i'm going
to stop right here
eastern all day you know the vlog total
is the kid mirror i
am proudly flat footed
a full six foot two inches catch you
with tim's on i'm six three and a half
holla at your boy this one is for the
jesus name
how tall is jesus nice well as anyone
who watches
and is on twitter knows my height is a
variable okay
so i told my program my height is a
veritable character that's 255
integers which means i could be five
three i could be six seven it's just the
past who's standing next to me i'm a
chameleon
all right you see me you don't know are
you getting short jesus are you getting
the short
insecure jesus that can't date a woman
that's taller than him or are you
getting
tall jesus who's six five where tim's on
a date you never know
i could be short i could be tall it's
whatever it's whatever you want me to be
if you want to cradle me like a newborn
i'm that height if you want me to be the
big part of the spoon
i'm that height it's whatever you want
baby i'm flexible i'm versus
who is the kid merrell oh a deep one hey
hey listen man the kid marrow is just
a kind-hearted soul who is here to
spread mirth and joy
to those that need it in these dark
times
and i'm also here to secure these bags
bro you know what i'm saying because two
chains ain't enough
you know what i'm saying i'm trying to
upgrade from the house to jersey you dig
fat joe said yo when you get money from
the bronx you
you know saying buy yourself an estate
in jersey and i said fat joe cruz mania
i salute you
you are a legend in the bronx and i will
follow your real estate advice you know
what i'm saying so i'm out here burger
king
that's who i am it's your boy who is the
kid mero family
not really an english question but hey
let's go big russian bot
energy right there yo yo for real shout
out to you for trying dual lingo and
failing you know what i'm saying
who is the kim merrell's family this is
my family what i'm saying
they are great and i love they're
they're wild but i love
what i'm saying there you go yo you've
been chopping up with your boy jesus
nice to the kim miro thank you for your
questions you're
yeah i'm saying we'll be back maybe